trading very well to further this
investigation the community has been
absolutely terrific as it comes to
reporting
information that they have things they
may have witnessed things they may have
seen turning over video that has really
helped us
further the investigation and aid
investigators one point i just want to
clarify is robert cremo the third he's
21 he'll be 22 in september of this year
and he's a resident of highwood
so throughout the past 24 hours
investigators have spoken with numerous
witnesses
some of the survivors they've had the
opportunity to review numerous video
clips both from cell phone video
recordings and fixed cameras in the area
and they've conducted a number of other
follow-up investigations and based on
where we're at at this point in the
investigation and some of this is still
preliminary so is subject to change as
we keep moving forward but we do believe
cremo pre-planned this attack for
several weeks
he brought a high-powered rifle to this
parade
he accessed the roof of a business via a
fire escape ladder
and began opening fire on the innocent
independence day celebration goers
the rifle was purchased in illinois and
the information we have thus far is that
it appears to have been purchased
legally by cremo
during the attack primo was dressed in
women's clothing and investigators do
believe he did this to conceal his
facial tattoos and his identity and help
him during the escape with the other
people who were fleeing the chaos
during the attack we believe that karimo
fired more than 70 rounds from this
rifle into the crowd of innocent people
following the attack cremo exited the
roof he dropped his rifle and he blended
in with the crowd and he escaped
he walked to his mother's home who lived
in the area and he blended right in with
everybody else as they were running
around almost as he was
an innocent spectator as well
he borrowed his mother's vehicle
we issued an alert yesterday afternoon
chief juggman provided the vehicle
information and primo's information
we're very thankful that an alert member
of the community saw karimo's vehicle
traveling southbound on route 41
dialed 9-1-1
an alert north chicago police officer
spotted the vehicle waited for
additional backup units to arrive
conducted a traffic stop and they were
able to safely apprehend primo with no
injuries to the officers
inside the vehicle there was a second
rifle located
indications is that was purchased by
cremo as well
thus far over 30 people were injured
during the attack and this does not
include the six who lost their lives
right now cremo remains in custody at
this time
there are no indications that there was
anybody else involved in this attack by
all indications it appears cremo was
acting by himself
the lake county state's attorney's
office has been with us from the ground
level they're with us this morning they
were with us through the night
we continue to review the information
investigators are still developing leads
and very critical information uh once
we're at a point where we're ready to
review all of that information for
charges we will sit down with the
state's attorney in review for criminal
charges